LaRose I'm not hotels Rami man what's up
what's with the sandals what about my
sandal what's your problem my problem my
problem is that every day I see you walk
out with those Jesus sandals and I can't
figure out why it's there to figure out
he's my favorite sandals I don't want
nothing else to wear so
oh we're we're but they're your only
shoes does your favorite dude and what
do you have a room full of sneakers that
you haven't worn the [ __ ] is all this
these are the shoes exactly
brand new [ __ ] shoes you
haven't worn my question to you is why
haven't you worn them simple these are
collectibles you never heard of
collectibles for you my friend have a
1962 My Little Pony you haven't opened
up once your little [ __ ] hey it's a
collectible these are shoes you're
supposed to wear all right okay that's
it I want you to wear one of these shoes
by today oh you have a sick obsession
dance today
I'm sorry ah here let's just start off
with my leave no we can't do that what
about these no but the whole mall can
you slap my hand one more time I'm gonna
cut your goddamn eyes up
whatever man I'm out of here you got a
problem you want to confront it you're a
big loser I'm a big loser listen how
many times have I told you what am i hmm
I'm a sneakerhead yeah don't put your
[ __ ] feet into these shoes it'll
cause a crease do you know what a
creases increase it's like what me about
your date I stick it in the mouth of the
Mon [ __ ] Lisa you're sick you're
you're mentally ill yeah you got oh it's
all right
hmm I can wear these shoes whatever I
want
I don't be able to see what the problem
is deliver man you know what go ahead
and [ __ ] your shoes I'm gonna [ __ ] your
sister Wow you know what hey how about
this shut up hey Jess yeah let's [ __ ]
okay oh I see finally why one of your
new kids yes sir dude I'm so proud of
you man thank you
I gotta tell you man I finally feel
liberated this is all thanks to you my
man all right yeah okay
yeah you ready to roll out yeah just
give me um
give me a couple minutes okay happy feet
what the [ __ ] you doing Lawrence this is
a compromise I put my feet in the shoes
but I began if I creasing them Jim you
and no just just walk up the stairs just
don't you can get on the pool dude you
can you're gonna break your stairs man
if you think this is weird you have to
say [ __ ] yet the [ __ ] this is guy that's
Kate Nicolas Cage
I don't see what the problem is man
problem was it's a hobby you'll have
hobbies
I'm not talking about your dolly man
that Nets besides Apulia it's the
principle behind it you spend thousands
of dollars in shoes that you don't even
wear listen I think the reason why we
don't see eye to eye speakers you don't
own a nice pair of shoes I own a nice
pair of shoes I own a couple nice pair
of shoes like what those right there
hobo couture where did you get those
looks like a paper mache project see
mine is the best look at that [ __ ] hey
don't be mean listen man I think I have
a solution
hey you know what you know what these
are
no my olympics here I want you to have I
don't want your shoes man try them on
and see what happens
anyway haven't scum you got [ __ ] I'm
walking him right now do it do it boy
see what happened Oh Chris oh shoot Oh
Laurie what you judge for you are now a
sneaker head
you
you